U
VENING, EVERYONEM KATE BFOBU
"OUTFRONT" TONIGHT A LOW BLOW  I
QUESTIONIN T
GUIDELINES.
PY WHAT
RESPON GOVER
>> DeSANTIS.
SURPRISEDEMBER
I GUESS THE QUON I
E FORGOTTEN?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CLEAR
LEANING INTOHIS
WELL.
TODAY BI
, SEND HIS CAMPAIGN
THIS. AUCISR DeSANTISBY PUBLIA
>> DeSANTIS HAS BEEN T
BLOCDES
ADMINISTRATIVE THE
EVO
SCIENCD E S.
G ATHERE HAS BUT
DOWN, I'M ANYO
WHY DON'T YOU DOOUB?I N' A BLIP
>> DeSANTIS T WA
DOESN'T
CHANGE THE RT HIS
STATE IS
MOREN  CIDHA
THIS WEEK.
THAT'SHE MOST CAS IN
SINCE  TLSREPORTING 5
AT WEEK.OU NEW CAS
SS TNT
REPORTED IFLOR
A STATE WITHS THAN% OFTODAY,ICAN
GON
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT KNOCK O HIS E
PANDEMIC>> WD NEWS
SPOF THE E WE'RE SED, THE VIRUST
YOBOUTDA
WI 21,CASES IN A D
THEY HAVE 10,000 PEOPLE IN THEI
EACH OF  LARRYON DeSANANE DEBUYI
GET US ANYR S
T OF THIND.
N LMLAREKNOW YOU'VE BEEN TALKIN
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ABOUT THI,
E OFCT
ING THE NEXT STEPSE TE OF WA
BETWEEN THE HOE NTIS.
THEY DEMONSTRATED
THIS WEEK TOT THOSE
GOVERNO LIKE
DeSANTIS WHO THEY BELIARE
MAKINGT FLHE
H GUIDANCE.
E SPECIFICALLY DeSANTIS AND TEXT
GOVERNORS WHT
MASK OCCINE REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT IS SOMETHINAT YOU
FROM WHITE HOUS
OFS  WEEK AS
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE.EAD O
ONE THING THIS W DETAK TO OFFIC
DECISIONS RDSKS AND VACCINE IR
MAATE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN DO  T
NG OE URSE B
WAR OF WORDS
CONTINUES IS GOING
FORWARD.  ARLET, THAN W CO-ANN
CAL TEAM OUINER THAT
NDG BY
CA THIOF WORDS?
>>O.ERE AS YOU
ALL, THE BIGGESTALE FOR THE
OLIC
WHETHER OR NOT POLN
TRYING TO ISOFF OF
TH DOING JUS IS TH
OTS Y IN T WHAS  MAL
T ARE
G ON IN FLORIDA.
SKYROCKETING AND SO ON AND
IWHNE IS ISSUE PEOPLEA AL VEL M
E IS AITF RICHONY IN DON THINK
E  TRADITI LOCAL, YES,UITE AIT
COVID OV TT WEEK  FLREE HE GUND
DeAN ANY
REQUIREMENTS FROM GOIN ND HONES
THORISER.
LOOK, I THINK THE PRIMARRNORHEHI
E IN HIS SNOW INLORIDA, TH A
ALREADY VERY HIGH TALY TO TH
RATES.
RIN
LY
HE PK RI THE EN4t IT'EOPLE GOVEI
MKSAN GET PUBLI
BUSINESSES TVAE ES O
PAPO TT DOWN
TH O
TO DALE .THE STATE IS ON D IF Y
T TH DEPARTHF A HOUSFIRE, THAT A
WHAT IS HAIN FRI
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE ANDY
IDHIS WE THS AR
G HT BEING TOO CAUGHT
BY HALF BE
WE W OF EMIC WITH TLITY.
PRESS                          E
BITHEL
IS ON TD AND THIS ISN'T,
THIT
NTENTS B HIS IA FIGHT ABOUR D AN
PRESIDENOFNITED STATES.
HE IN CHAR O
THOUE LOCA
LT THAT IS T
GO
ABLY
IS FROM A MUCH MORE
E
OBVIOUSLY
H RE RY
SAYING -- EDLA
LOOK AE CS,  ONE OF THE CES BET
HU L
UNNINGTH
SO HE'S MAYBE MORE FE TO SAY
RATHERN DeSANTIS.WHETHER  N
24T DOESN'
LOOKING AT THE NEXEL
HIS STATE TON
TTLY RIGH, IT CIMPLE LAIDS
SAD US IS TERMT ANG FOME
.
DOCTOR, HEFUNDRAG IS IN  OF THE
ATE, SELLING TS ND ACASE STUFF
HAVEL CONSEQUENCE RIGHT W?
S HAPPENING ON THE
OUNDN FLORIDA RI
THE
CTIONS IS CREATINGAT
PAENL RI
DER TOGENCY COURES
ORRES.
IN FRIHEOVERNOR, I I THIS PAEM
HIMSELFA
OI T